Mia Khalifa has gone viral in this case
because she was recounting a very ugly
incident that happened to her at a
restaurant I get come up to by this guy
and his girlfriend and we were
interrupted in the middle of talking and
eating and he said hey mifa can I get a
picture with you and I looked up at him
and I'm like no we're eating and I said
it just like that like it was it was a
rude way but it was also very rude for
him to come up while someone was
actively in the middle of a conversation
and after I said that his girlfriend who
was standing next to him grabbed him by
the arm and said I told you that wasn't
her there's not enough on her face let's
go babe and I went into the bathroom and
cried and I didn't really know how to
handle it especially cuz it came from a
woman and especially because I was I
like I was I was there for business and
it was something that had nothing to do
with the adult industry and I was just
very dejected and embarrassed I kind of
feel bad for meia Khalifa here every
single person involved in this story is
just terrible